[Music]
after four long years the second season
of one punch man began in April the
action characters and sense of heroic
endeavors is what brought many of us
back each week to see what our favorite
caped Baldy and the other odd but
lovable heroes are up to and who they'll
be fighting next season two brought the
arrival of fan favorites Fubuki and Garo
as well as the beginnings of the monster
association and the chaos they bring now
the season two's finished we're counting
down the best moments that have helped
make this season more than memorable
so no hanashi magic idol
cos obamacare chemo sambusa dr. death
kicking off this list we have Kings
truth one of the highest-ranked S Class
Heroes regarded for his strength and
chillingly intimidating features is
revealed at the beginning of the series
to be nothing more than an otaku King
reveals to Saitama and Generals at the
start of the season that he took credit
for another hero who managed a huge
defeat and was living under that light
ever since it turns out later in the
episode that it was Saitama who
spotlight King stole a strange with
humorous end to the beginning of an
action packed season sure
[Music]
[Music]
boy Santos imminent comment another
panel goes at number 9 we have Garros
declaration as the hero killer this
season wastes no time is showing who the
major antagonist for the series will be
the criminal underworld villains were
invited by the hero association to a
meeting by sitch
to discuss working together but Goro's
quick to declare himself the hero hunter
and everyone else as his enemy Garo
beats everyone up to the point of not
being able to get up or apart from sitch
he shows everyone that he's a force to
be reckoned with
which is left to carry the news that
there's a hero hunter on the loose
goro leaves and making us eager to see
what his next set of plans will be who
he ends up going up against next and how
it will fare for both him and the hero
that ends up as his next opponent they
will murder
[Music]
cause look
next we have Jenness versus sonic it's
no surprise to the die-hard one-punch
man found that Genesis and Sonic are on
the opposite sides of the spectrum when
it comes to how they've used saitama
Jenna sees him as a powerful ally and a
teacher while Sonic sees him is the
greatest threat in someone he must
defeat in order to continue moving
forward
it's incredible to watch the two collide
for the first time each giving it their
all to not only take out the enemy
before them but to also prove to the
other that their feelings and ideas
surrounding Saitama were not only
stronger but the correct way to view him
the fight does end in a draw though as
Sonic is much too fast for generals to
hit and Genesis too durable for Sonic to
do any lasting damage a draw that
neither seem to be thrilled with are
forced to accept Cheadle Naumann john
Ezell camaro
[Music]
next up it's Saitama versus Fubuki and
her henchmen during jane austen Sonic's
fight we have the fight between hellish
blizzard and Saitama hellish blizzard or
Fubuki is the top-ranked B class hero
and intends to recruit Saitama to her
organization which he refuses to do in
an effort to show how powerful she is
and why he should change his mind
fubuki attacked Saitama with everything
she's got along with her henchmen - now
the fight is one-sided and despite the
numbers she's taken down by Saitama with
ease in the end Saitama tells Fubuki to
truly be strong she must learn to remind
more on herself rather than those around
her this is a warning that would prove
to be important to fubuki later on in
season 2
dammit amina go to school sandy hank
roohani
fortunately at 6 we have Garo versus
tank top army Garros first big fight
against several strong heroes showed not
only that he's a daring hero but also
that he's quite the adversary Gaara
makes easy work of topsy ranked hero
Moomin Rider the s-class ranked tank top
master and silver fangs apprentice
Toronto it seems the worries of the
other s-rank Heroes is true as Garrow is
unbelievably strong now and it appears
he won't stop until he's defeated every
hero he comes into contact with
[Music]
[Laughter]
next is garrow's backstory at number
five
every villains backstory tells a lot
about their character and garrow's no
exception as a child he began to root
for monsters and villains because he
believed it was unfair of heroes to
always win his father told him good guys
win because they're good and that's the
only reason why further ideas of heroes
being too popular and monster seen as
freaks would eventually push Gaara over
the edge outraged by seeing the villains
trying just as hard to win as the heroes
Garo tips the scale more even further
towards the villains by throwing himself
into the fray with his motive now known
and several heroes already been taken
down by his hands Goro takes off to find
his next target to fight doctor or her
dad anymore balcony sight or
occasionally not there
[Music]
Sweden civil
so he to the doctor
the unit number four is metal bat versus
monsters metal bats fight against elder
centipede was a long and weary invitin
the high ranking hero not only did metal
behalf to pull through with numerous
monsters attacking him but immediately
after the fight Garo challenges him
metal bat engages the hero murderer and
is defeated Gaara says that if metal bat
landed even just a single hit he would
have been defeated overcome by anger
because of this metal bat attempts to
strike Garo down based off from being
killed thanks to his younger sister
Zenko girl leaves metal bat alone
revealing he has a soft spot for kids
and fuss metal bat survives his
encounter with Garo dust girl your book
where does this video
[Music]
yoku story da-da-da-da-da Marc Accetta
at number three we have saitama's heroic
saving of Syria despite all the panic
with Garros item has been busy
undercover at a martial arts tournament
to find out more information about him
and also to try and further himself he
meets Syria along the way who tries to
convince him to give up on being a hero
and used the power just for himself
following saitama's disqualification a
monster fight barkos and nearly beat
Syria to death despite their differences
Saitama saves him and the others from
the bar cruising with a single punch and
shows the martial artist that using your
powers for the benefit of others does
indeed have its own personal rewards so
moved by this gesture by Saitama Syria
sees himself wanting to become a hero as
well co-ceo he toka pinna sorry most of
the kid a gonna say Tomica or there see
nice Nikola Nagar
that tiny hotel
[Music]
at number 2 we have Garrow vs heroes
episode 11 was definitely one of the
best episodes of the season especially
with the brilliant fight animations
gorona only faces off in this fight
against several top-ranked heroes like
chain and toad gun gun shooter Wildhorn
and death Gatling but also s ranked
heroes like Jennison bang genis who
arrived on the scene thanks to a call
for backup quickly proves he's a
difficult adversary to go out with his
new upgrades soon we see bang and his
brother bomb make a grand entrance the
two master martial artists prepare to
end his life but Garo in his anger and
despair commences a counterattack with
tank top masters tank top blow
unfortunately the fight ends abruptly
due to phoenix man and elder centipede
which brings us conveniently to our
number1 moments
finally at number one we have the s-rank
heroes versus Elder centipede and
monsters with the season nearly over
it's no surprise that the entire arcs
been leading up to an all-out brawl
against the monster threat that's been
looming over all season but with elder
centipede coming back and ready to
strike revenge against the heroes of
this world we can know for sure that our
favorite caped baldies gonna make an
appearance and save the day with a huge
number of s-rank heroes Garo Saitama and
monsters are all in one place and it
leads to a big heart pounding bra as the
closer for the season this is when we
see Saitama perform his serious series
serious punch again the force of the
punch is too much for elder centipedes
regeneration and his body crumbles
marking his permanent defeat the second
season of one punch man has hopefully
filled the fist shaped hole in our
hearts that the first season left behind
through this season we've been
introduced to new characters reunited
with old ones and watch the villains
fall but once again it's time to say
goodbye so make sure you show your
support to the show and also read the
manga if you haven't already I'm telling
you it's really awesome thanks for
watching this video be sure to leave a
like subscribe for more great anime
content and leave a comment telling us
what your favorite moment from one punch
man second season was I'll see you next
time on vinnie tube
[Music]